heather is kind of the only former
housewife that has stayed in your orbit
yeah what is it about her that this is a
friendship that used to normal et was on
hand for a little real housewives
reunion as Tamra judge recorded the
Heather dubrow's world podcast I mean
love Mike
I mean I'm always willing to get the
answers out of them probably not the
answer has changed it's always been
Never Say Never
- now it's probably not well you know I
would say never say never because you
know if in two years I was back up
starting would be like you know well you
know they're coming in a different
direction they like the way it's going I
you know you never know what life is
gonna bring you but it's like I'm in a
good spot is it more something in your
life would have to change or something
on this show side of things would have
to change a question yeah yeah what do
you what do you think Tamara um I don't
think the show is ever gonna change so I
really does it I feel like you're a
freaking what you are
[Music]
this is low thanks bull I'm not doing
this Kelly
this behavior is not acceptable Philippe
feel like when certain maybe characters
and I will say characters are brought on
to be incendiary and and you know like
the match then that takes me a little
bit back so that fair to say it's fair
to say I would never say that Rally GB
is not for everybody yeah it's not I'm
gonna say maybe if a person who likes to
secretly film people out to have an
orange theory weren't on the show the
chances might be greater for you coming
back Heather Dubrow isn't sitting there
I'm trying to avoid her at all cost
trying to get my work out and she won't
leave the area
stop talking and you get my work out and
I don't want to run any yeah and if they
like to film outside like you know cut
Fitness or I feel like secretly filming
might be something that happens on the
show all right there might be brought up
Haley is it brought up this here maybe
shut up
some people like to secretly film okay
all I'm saying if I had a mic I drop it
right now fans should get to see more
mic drop moments from Tamara soon as Rho
C returns to Bravo
this summit this season I know you can't
say a whole she did spill some but I'm
reading sources day yeah that she's no
longer a full housewife well did she did
you ask you did post that it's gonna be
one of the most amazing seasons yet oh
yes is that photo of you Shannon
possibly the new housewife dancing on
your countertop indicative of the season
that's how the season started so that's
early on in the season we're at my house
which I had recently moved and we're
having a housewarming party
it was just fun one word to describe the
new season real that's all I can say it
so it's just real-life stuff that's
going on and I mean obviously I haven't
seen what I lived it yes
so it it's gonna be good I mean I we
needed it though I feel like we came off
a couple seasons there were a little
weak and I feel like it's good like Gina
and Emily which were newbies last year
really stepped up the game that's good
to hear I mean obviously Gina had a lot
going on in her life
yeah and I think everybody's gonna be
shocked at me Gina really was a rock
star this season well if I had Shaam
salad cheers to that
Cheers good to see you guys I know if I
could get you back on the show other oh
do that exit stage left
I wonder how it has the champagne level
been since I've left oh good question
[Music]